bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat place à présent à
l'audition de Laurent Fabius l'ancien
ministre des Affaires étrangères qui a
quitté le gouvernement mercredi dernier
son départ était d'ailleurs à l'origine
du remanimement puisqu'il est le
candidat au Conseil constitutionnel de
François Hollande candidat même à la la
présidence du Conseil constitutionnel
puisque le mandat de Jean-Louis Debray
doit toucher à sa fin au printemps
Laurent Fabius finalement ne cumulera
pas cette fonction avec celle de
président de la cop21 même si c'était
son souhait de d'art mais voilà cela
pose un problème en terme de séparation
des pouvoirs or le Conseil
constitutionnel doit rester un organe
indépendant d'ailleurs Laurent fabus
lors d'une interview cette semaine l'a
rappel il s'agit pour lui d'un véritable
achèvement dans sa carrière politique
carrière lors de laquelle il a occupé
quasiment toutes les fonctions
législatives et exécutives existantes
sauf bien sûr celle de président de la
République tout de suite donc place à
l'audition de Laurent
Fabius la Constitution prévoit que vous
soyez auditionné par chacune des deux
assemblées c'est ce que nous faisons ce
matin à la commission des lois
euh votre vie publique est tellement
connue qu'elle me dispense de rappeler
ces grandes étapes en revanche la
missission des lois sera intéressé parce
que vous pourrez lui dire dans un
premier temps de ce qui fonde votre
souhait d'accepter
cette nouvelle nouvelle
mission si vous voulez bien peut-être
vous exprimer pendant une vingtaine de
minutes davantage si vous le souhaitez
moins si vous voulez être plus concis de
sorte que nos collègues puissent ils le
souhaiteront certainement vous posez un
certain nombre de de questions y compris
euh sur euh les orientations à venir du
Conseil constitutionnel donc je vous
cède la parole merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs merci
de maccueillir pour cette audition
euh
juridiquement si je comprends bien les
choses euh puisque je suis pressenti
comme membre par le président de la
République euh je dois être auditionné
par les deux commissions je viens d'être
auditionné par la commission de
l'Assemblée nationale et maintenant je
me trouve avec plaisir devant vous le
président de la République n'a pas fait
mystère de ce que si euh je devais être
membre du Conseil constitutionnel j'en
serai le président mais sans faire de
juridisme je comprends que c'est à titre
de membre que vous mod'uditionnez et non
pas de
président possible euh merci infiniment
oui
euh c'est vrai que mon parcours est
connu euh peut-être puis-je revenir sur
deux aspects de ce parcours qui vous
intéresseront plus particulièrement euh
par rapport aux fonctions que le cas
échéant je vais remplir et puis
peut-être dira-je quelques mots si vous
voulez bien sur la façon dont je perçois
le Conseil
constitutionnel alors il faudrait au
début de chacune de mes phrases ajouter
si les commissions et cetera je ne le
ferai pas non pas par présomption mais
pour gagner du temps et
aussi je dois dire que pour des raisons
évidentes j'essaierai de répondre bien
sûr à toutes vos questions mais en même
temps je peux pas prendre une position
trop claire sur des questions sur
lesquelles je peux être amené bien sûr à
prendre position dans mes fonctions
futures et hypothétiques euh sur mon
propre cheminement
euh je mettrai l'accent sur deux aspects
au fond j'ai eu beaucoup de chance parce
que j'avais une formation au départ
littéraire économique juridique et j'ai
commencé mon parcours au Conseil d'État
euh où je me trouvais d'ailleurs avec
Monsieur Richard voilà euh c'était il y
a quelques années et donc j'ai appris le
le
droit la rigueur l'indépendance
nécessaire au Conseil d'État et j'y suis
resté 4
années au contentieux comme on dit euh à
l'époque j'appartenais à une
sous-section présidée par Bernard tricot
grand juriste et il a eu d'autres
fonctions dans la République
et un homme tout à fait remarquable et
c'est lui qui m'a appris le
droit j'ai fait partie de ce qu'on
appelle le centre de documentation du
Conseil d'État je sais pas si ça existe
toujours
bon et donc
voilà c'est un peu lointain mais au fond
la formation qu'on y acquierre elle
demeure toute la vie et ce qui m'app
aussi euh et c'est un point euh très
important pour au fond toutes les
fonctions qu'on peut exercer c'est que
le Conseil d'État bon au contentieux il
faut préparer des décisions on les juge
et évidemment on apprend la
jurisprudence et cetera mais le point
peut-être le plus intéressant c'est que
ça vous apprend ça vous oblige à prendre
la totalité d'un raisonnement pour aller
du point A au point Z en examinant
toutes les bifurcations possibles
et cette façon de
travailler bien sûr elle est absolument
indispensable dans le domaine du droit
mais elle est très très utile dans tous
les secteurs de la vie parce que elle
vous
oblige avoir toutes les conséquences de
ce que vous pouvez faire non pas pour
vous conduire à être paralysé mais pour
quand même anticiper un certain nombre
de conséquences de ce que vous pouvez
décider en tout cas donc le droit je
dois dire que je n'ai pas depuis euh
regardé tous les soirs la le recueil le
bon mais disons que cette formation elle
ne s'oublie pas et que j'ai aimé la
formation que que j a acquise euh
ensuite évidemment comme ministre comme
premier ministre comme euh parlementaire
comme président de l'Assemblée j'ai eu à
pratiquer le droit mais d'une autre
façon mais donc cette ce rôle de de juge
je l'ai exercé ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point d' un aspect
évidemment moins connu de mon parcours
c'est l'aspect local parce que les
choses sont ainsi fait que le National
étouffe le local bon
et comme j'ai eu la la chance de pouvoir
exercer beaucoup de fonctions
nationales mon ancrage
local il n'est il n'est pas connu enfin
connu peut-être de vous et en
particulier de de l'un de vos collègues
qui a été mon mon suppléant euh mais en
tout cas pas pas de la grande opinion or
euh j'y réfléchissais en préparant cette
audition au fond mon parcours c'est euh
parcours d'un élu national puisque j'ai
été élu député euh la première fois en
1978 et euh les électeurs ont eu
l'imprudence de enfin c'est le jugement
qui est souverain de Me rélir depuis à
chaque fois
mais j'ai exercé des fonctions locales
j'ai donc été conseiller municipal
adjoint
maire expérience
extraordinaire j'ai été conseiller
général au moment où ça s'appelait
encore comme ça j'ai été président de
région mais pas dans le nouveau système
dans le système ancien j'ai été
président d'une agglomération
l'agglomération de rouan extrêmement
intéressant aussi euh
donc je crois avoir fait la totalité du
du parcours local
et je je ferai la la même réponse que
celle que font beaucoup d'entre vous
lorsque on les interroge quel est la
fonction qui vous a le plus intéressé
c'est celle-là
euh parce que on prend des décisions on
voit les conséquences de ces décisions
alors que au niveau des grandes
fonctions nationales ou internationale
je ne dis pas qu'on ne voit jamais les
conséquences de ces décision
heureusement on les voit
mais dans certains cas bon c'est
tellement diffus que on n pas cette
sanction immédiate de l'électeur bon pe
être élu local une fois par hasard mais
quand on est reconduit il y a pas de
hasard bon et donc pourquoi dis cela
parce que je pense que si j'exerce des
fonctions au Conseil
constitutionnel cette dimension là de
l'élu
local ça je la garderai toute ma vie et
donc
j'examinerai les décisions que nous
aurons à prendre avec d'une part cette
formation juridique que j'ai eu la
chance d'acquérir et puis cette
dimension locale en même temps j'étais
parlementaire je dois vous prier de
m'excuser je n' étis que député bon
mais je fais partie de cette catégorie
don je ne sais pas si elle est nombreuse
ou pas au
fond bon quand on interroge les députés
il y a deux grandes catégories de
députés par rapport à la question du
bicamérisme ceux qui sont carrément
contre et ceux qui sont contre mais
ensuite qui vont devenir
sénateurs et moi je fais partie de cette
3è catégorie je sais pas si nombreuse je
ne crois pas avoir pris position contre
le Sénat pour une raison assez simple
c'est que je suis partisan du
bicamérisme alors là je dois dire je
vous présente mes
excuses et je dis pas cela seulement
parce que je suis devant vous mais bon
je pense qu'il y a un équilibre à
trouver alors on peut bien sûr critiquer
les positions prises par les uns et par
les autres mais je trouve que dans dans
notre démocratie telle qu'elle existe à
condition bien sûr qu'il nit pas de
blocage le fait qu'il puisse y avoir
voir un un équilibre est intéressant et
important
euh et
puis évidemment ça a une incidence sur
notre sujet notre thème mais
euh le le Sénat pas seulement récemment
mais depuis très longtemps a un intérêt
particulier pour les question de liberté
de droit donc ça ça concerne au premier
chef le Conseil constitutionnel sur les
questions aussi de collectivité locale
de décentralisation et donc tout ceci
fait que
euh bon
euh c'est une préparation une
propédutique qui qui me paraît utile
pour les les la fonction qui m'a été
proposée donc voilà sur ma vie euh
ensuite sur le
Conseil bon j'ai eu à à faire à
plusieurs reprises au Conseil
constitutionnel bien sûr j'ai eu
l'occasion deux fois de nommer un
représentant quand je présidais
l'Assemblée nationale que vous avez
peut-être connu j'ai nommé le professeur
Jacques Robert qui un grand juriste et
ensuite le professeur Jean-Claude
coliard
et donc à cette occasion bien sûr
j'avais réfléchi au conditions des
nominations et
bon moi-même signé des recours bien
sûr eu des rapports nombreux avec cette
institution mais je ne peux pas dire que
je la connaisse de
l'intérieur je sais que ces membres sont
en général des gens tout à fait éminents
et bon c'est une occasion bien sûr de de
rendre hommage au aux membres actuels et
aux membres qui s'en vont bon et en
particulier ceux qui ont été désignés
par le président du Sénat mais plus
largement tous ses membres et au au
président qui s'en
va le président de Bray euh sur le
Conseil bon il y a il y a plusieurs
phases au départ le Conseil parl franc a
été créé
pour empêcher que le Parlement empiète
sur l'exécutif c'était ça l'idée bon et
puis ensuite comme ça arrive dans
l'histoire les choses ont évolué pour
des
raisons certaines anecdotiques dit méthe
de fond c'est la question de fond qui
compte avec plusieurs phases
essentielles bon ce qui s'est passé en
en juillet 71 même si ça avait été
préparé un petit peu à l'avance
avec cette décision sur la liberté
d'associationà c'était un changement
considérable puisque le contrôle ne se
faisait pas simplement par rapport aux
différents articles de la Constitution
mais par rapport à son préambule au
préambule de 46 et puis la déclar tion
de des droits évidemment ça changeait
énormément de choses alors la question
est posée peut-être reviendon là-dessus
est-ce que c'est un juge pas un juge oui
c'est un juge bien sûr un juge c'est
c'est ça fait c'est pas seulement un
juge mais c'est un juge donc les choses
ont beaucoup bougé en 71 ils ont bougé à
nouveau en 74 lorsque les 60 députés ou
60 sénateurs ont pu à l'intiative
c'était à l'époque le président
jiscardestin saisir le conseil donc ça
changeait beaucoup les choses euh et
puis euh disons le troisième grand
changement même s'il y en a eu entre
tempemps c'est c'est l'affaire de la QPC
le président Sarkozy ça avait été
auparavant proposé ça n'avait pas pu
prospérer donc 2008 application en 2010
la QPC et euh pour préparer cette
audition bon j'ai repris tout ça j'ai
j'ai essayé de me former un jugement
peut-être on en parlera en tout cas je
suis à votre disposition je pense que
l'institution était utile bon même s'il
y a toujours des choses à compléter et
donc quand on rapproche ces deux
éléments à la fois mon parcours
personnel et puis l'évolution du Conseil
constitutionnel je crois
que l'expérience que j'ai acquise
l'indépendance que je
porte font que je peux être utile et
finalement c'est toujours la même idée
servir la République les citoyens même
si c'est une fonction différente puisque
j'ai exercé la plupart des fonctions
exécutives et législatives et maintenant
c'est autre chose donc je l'ai souhaité
je le dis clairement et lorsque le
président de la République m'a proposé
cela et bien céit un grand honneur et
cet honneur la mise en application de
cet honneur dépend maintenant de vous
voilà où j'en suis euh et donc je suis
vraiment à votre disposition pour
répondre à toutes vos questions même si
je le disais je devrais normalement pour
ne pas être
présomptueux faire procéder avant chaque
réponse de la formule
si bien mais disons que par économie de
moyen comme on dit je ne ferai pas mais
enfin le l'idée est là
et en même temps ne m'envoillez pas je
n'ai pas
euh une connaissance au jour le jour de
tout ce que fait le Conseil
constitutionnel euh je bien sûr je me
suis mis à jour j'ai rencontré le
secrétaire général du conseil très
compétent et sont prédécesseur aussi euh
mais disons que j'ai plein de bonne
volonté pour
apprendre merci Monsieur le Premier
Ministre je vais vous poser une première
question euh le président
Debray s'est exprimé publiquement pour
évoquer les évolutions récentes et
notamment la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité mais il a aussi
envisagé l'avenir pour le Conseil
constitutionnel et il a
notamment souligner l'intérêt qui de son
point de vue s'attacherait à ce que le
Conseil constitutionnel exerce un
contrôle de conventionnalité je crois
que ça intéresserait la commission que
vous lu fassiez part de votre sentiment
sur cette
question je donne la parole si vous le
permettez peut-être enfin si si vous le
souhaitez c'est peut-être plus commode
oui alors madame taskaa
merci monsieur le Président tout d'abord
moi je saisis l'opportunité de cette
audition pour vous dire Monsieur le
Premier Ministre toute l'admiration que
m'inspire la façon dont vous avez rempli
votre mission à la tête du ministère des
Affaires étrangères je crois qu'avec
vous la diplomatie française a
conforté sa dignité et aussi son
ambition ce qui est très important pour
notre pays et vous avez évoqué la la
grande réforme des des des QPC euh c'est
en
effet un changement assez considérable
dans
euh la mission du Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce que
vous pensez même si vous l'avez dit vous
n'avez pas vécu de l'intérieur le
Conseil ces dernières années est-ce que
vous pensez que cela pourrait conduire à
une certaine réorganisation du Conseil
constitutionnel dans la mesure où ça
change sensiblement le le poids des
charges qui qui sont les siennes et puis
nous vivons dans un ordre juridique qui
est le nôtre qui est l'ordre juridique
français mais également dans l'ordre
juridique
international bien sûr et notamment
européen est-ce que cela peut à votre
avis poser des questions particulières
au rôle du Conseil
constitutionnel merci chers collègues
monsieur
Vassel merci monsieur le Président deux
questions à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la
première est-ce que il vous est arrivé
de considérer que le Conseil
constitutionnel par ses jugements a
rendu des jugements qui étaient plus en
opportunité qu'en regard du droit
constitutionnel la deuxème
question c'est avoir votre sentiment
alors c'est dépend votre qualité de
memre du Constitutionnel que vous
pourriez y répondre le moment venu mais
peut-être de l'expérience qui est la
vôre comme à la fois élus local et
parlementairire et et membres du
gouvernement nous avons réformé le
Conseil Constitution n à une certaine
époque là dans les dans les 15 dernières
années qui a permis au Sénat de d'être
saisi en première lecture de tous les
textes de loi qui concernaient donc nos
collectivités locales moi je fais partie
de ceux qui pensaient qu'on aurait pu
permettre au Sénat d'avoir le dernier
mot sur tout ce qui concernait les
institutions locales et nos
collectivités locales est-ce que vous
pensez qu'une telle évolution du droit
constitutionnel qui permettrait au Sénat
d'avoir le dernier mot sur ce sujets
serait opportune ou non peut-être on
peut sarrêter là parce qu'après je je
risque de ne pas avoir dans ma mémoire
le détail des questions et puis on fera
un si ça vous convient oui oui et puis
on on on fera une deuxième non pas une
deuxème salle mais une deuxième série de
questions ensuite merci beaucoup
euh monsieur le Président d'abord pour
faire suite à votre à votre première
intervention euh oui le le président
Jean-Louis
Debré
notamment dans les vœux la réponse au
vœux qu'il a faite il y a quelques jours
au président de la République a non pas
livré un testament mais livraer un
certain nombre de points sur lequel il
pense qu'il pourrait y avoir des
évolutions
euh j'en ai noté deux ou trois euh
il cite cette question de la du contrôle
la conventionnalité
euh il s'interroge aussi sur la question
de
savoir
si il ne pourrait pas y avoir des
autorités administrative indépendante
qui saisirait le
conseil et puis il prend position sur la
question bien connu des membres de droit
les anciens présidents de la République
et ceteraon peut-être il y aura-t-il des
questions là-dessus mais sur la question
question du contrôle de conventionnalité
moi encore une fois sous bénéfice de
l'expérience parce que je crois que on
peut avoir un certain nombre d'idées on
doit en avoir d'ailleurs mais ensuite il
faut garder la réalité et se faire son
jugement mais sur cette question là je
suis plutôt je dirais du genre
classique bon il y a des organisations
juridiques qui sont différentes dans
chaque pays il y a a des pays où il n'y
a pas la séparation entre la juridiction
administrative et la juridiction
judiciaire il y a des pays où il y a une
cour suprêmeon tel n'est pas le cas de
la France donc il faut tenir compte
évidemment de la réalité
institutionnelle du pays auquel on
appartient mais dans tous les cas c'est
tout à fait vrai et je fais écho aussi à
ce que dit Madame taska puisque les
choses recoupe
euh la norme internationale et
singulièrement la norme européenne
devient de plus en plus importante dans
dans nos vies donc la question est euh
comment on concilie tout ça
euh jusqu'à présent euh le Conseil
constitutionnel dit bon contrôle de
constitutionnalité oui mais contrôle de
conventionnalité non pour simplifier en
revanche les autres juridictions
euh judiciaire administrative il peut y
avoir un contrôle euh alors certains
disent euh il y a des arguments pour ça
bon il faudrait changer les choses et ça
pourrait se faire d'ailleurs par
décision prétorielle euh le Conseil
constitutionnel compte tenu de
l'importance maintenant de ces normes
doit pouvoir contrôler
bon vous me demandez mon sentiment euh
là tel que d'une part le Conseil a
fonctionné jusqu'ici et dans l'état
actuel de mon d'analyse je suis plutôt
pour ce qu'on appelle le dialogue des
juges dialogue des juges c'est une
expression vous le savez qui était
employé par Bruno jeunevie qui été mon
collègue au Conseil d'État qui é un puit
de science et qui ensuite a été
secrétaire général du Conseil
constitutionnel quand Robert banater le
présidait et ensuite qui est revenu au
Conseil d'État il a dû présider la
section du contentieux
et il a comme commissaire du
gouvernement avant de d'aller au Conseil
il avait élaboré la la théorie dit du
dialogue des juges qui se différenciait
de la thèse du gouvernement des juges
bon et au fond l'idée est la suivante
euh il y a un contrôle de
constitutionnalité très
bien il ne doit pas y avoir dans la
jurisprudence du Conseil de contrôle de
conventionnalité mais en revanche compte
tenu de l'importance qu'à la norme
juridique européenne euh de la Cour de
justice tel ou tel élement il doit y
avoir de plus en plus un dialogue des
juges je pense que c'est une approche
assez pragmatique euh mais je la crois
assez juste et euh donc
euh aujourd'hui au moment où je
m'exprime je crois que c'est dans cette
direction du dialogue des juges qu'il
faudrait aller ça n'empêche pas un
certain nombre d'évolutions j'ai vu par
exemple que euh il y avait eu euh euh un
renvoi une question qui était posée par
le Conseil constitutionnel à une
autorité européenne donc tout cela
existe et il faut toujours utiliser
cette souplesse prétorienne mais en
terme de grands principe je pense
que il
faut plutôt en rester au contrôle de
constitutionnalité euh madame TASC
d'abord merci infiniment pour votre
appréciation sur l'action diplomatique
qui est maintenant derrière moi euh mais
une remarque quand même je l'ai fait
aussi je dois vous le dire devant vos
collègues députés qui me disait mais
enfin dans quel sens est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il peut y avoir des évolutions
alors je me garde comme ça de dire voilà
ça doit aller dans ce sens-là de mais il
y a un point tout de même sur lequel je
pense
il faut qu'il y ait des évolutions c'est
ce que
j'appellerais
la le rayonnement du droit
français j'ai vu ça en particulier dans
mes dernières fonctions qu'est-ce qui
fait le rayonnement de la
France beaucoup d'éléments la dimension
économique la dimension défense la
dimension principielle la dimension et
ce mais la dimension juridique est
extrêmement important parce que dans le
monde où nous sommes celui qui fixe la
norme c'est une partie de son
rayonnement qui en dépend or nous sommes
dans un monde compétitif où de plus en
plus la norme est anglosaxon et le droit
anglosaxon et je pense que pour
simplifier le droit français et sans
arrogance doit
pouvoir être défendu étendu en montrant
la qualité de ces solutions euh c'est
quelque chose qui a commencé d'être fait
mais je pense et j'espère et là
peut-être que mon expérience précédente
peut être utile euh je crois que c'est
une dimension extrêmement intéressante
qui peut prendre différentes formes je
répète sans arrogance il n' pas de sens
de dire voilà le droit français doit
s'appliquer et va s'appliquer à
l'ensemble des pays non mais on doit
pouvoir montrer et sans artifice que nos
solutions notre approche française du
droit droit constitutionnel et droit en
général est quelque chose d'utile et je
pense que c'est un point sur lequel on
devrait pouvoir insister alors madame
TASC me
demande si compte tenu de la novation
que représente les QPC du premier bilan
qu'on peut en tirer est-ce que ça doit
entraîner
des réformes de l'organisation du
Conseil avez vous dit et vous pensez
notamment à la question des
charges la réforme constitutionnelle
date de 2008 et son application est de
2010 donc nous avons derrière nous 6
années de pratique je pense qu'il faudra
faire un bilan et je crois que pour ne
pas attendre les calandr grec on
pourrait déjà faire un bilan 10 ans
après la réforme constitutionnelle
elle-même
c'est-à-dire en 2018 bon
euh de ce que euh je comprends euh
d'abord c'est un progrès indiscutable
parce que ça donne des droits nouveaux
euh aux citoyens et ça permet
euh d'examiner euh la constitutionnalité
d'éléments qui sinon étaiit interdit euh
à toute vérification euh donc c'est
positif au départ il y avait de
l'incertitude le nombre a été
extrêmement fort au départ et puis il
semble qu'il est une stabilisation
maintenant et on peut la comprendre
cette stabilisation parce que partir du
moment où de plus en plus de textes
antérieurs auront été investigués
euh bon même si le Conseil s'interdit
d'investiguer au-delà de ce qui lui est
demandé dans le cadre de la QPC euh ça
devrait réduire quand même
progressivement un certain nombre
d'éléments al le Conseil s'est organisé
pour cela et l'une des tradutions
concrètes c'est qu'il y a énormément de
travail ça c'est sûr puisque j'ai là les
chiffres mais bon en moyenne on me dit
que maintenant des CPC il y en a à peu
près 70 75 par an bon quand vous
considérez que ce sont des questions
souvent complexes que euh il faut
répondre dans les 3 mois que jamais le
Conseil n'a dépassé le délai qui lu a
été fixé au contraire et s' force de
juger plus rapidement ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup de travail enfin c'est normal
euh est-ce que il y a des modifications
dans l'organisation je le cas échéant je
verrai euh mais euh je pense que pour le
moment c'est fait d'une manière
satisfaisante enfin c'est le jugement
qui est
porté alors le président Debray
dans son mot pour le le futur a dit
mais me rappelle plus la formulation
exacte peut-être faudrait-il que les
autorités administratives indépendantes
notamment le défenseur de droit
puissent saisir le Conseil là encore je
voudrais me former mon jumement mais
inst anément je ne suis pas trop
favorable je vous le dis euh j'espère ne
pas choquer les uns et les autres
d'abord parce que les autorités
administrative indépendante sont des
autorités tout à fait remarquables mais
enfin c'est pas le Parlement comme ça et
en plus faut pas non plus trop charger
la barque si je peux dire bon
donc bon travaillons bien sur les QPC
alors les QPC ont un succès considérable
y compris dans des affaires un peu
spectaculaires bon euh bon mais vous
savez la règle moi c'est celle que j'ai
appris au Conseil d'État c'est qu'il
faut juger les affaires extraordinaires
de manière ordinaire ça c'est vraiment
la règle
et donc il y a sûrement des amodiations
mais je pense pas qu'il doivent y avoir
de bouleversement dans l'organisation
puisque c'était votre question madame
taska euh du decpc et d'autre part il
faut dire que la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitionnel notamment le fait
que
pour l'application l'exécution des QPC
il a une jurisprudence très subtile qui
parfois d'ailleurs est surprenant mais
que je trouve logique par exemple
parfois il dit qu'il faut appliquer un
texte qu'il considère comme
inconstitutionnel pendant la période
intermédiaire parce que si on arrêtait
du jour au lendemain bon c'est là où on
voit que il est bon d'avoir à la fois
des juristes mais qui en même
temps soit au fait des conséquences
pratiques de ce qu'il décide
je pense notamment à la décision sur la
garde à vue bon si on avait arrêté du
jour au lendemain qu'est-ce qui arrivait
bon
donc pour le moment enfin de ce que je
vois sans être encore un spécialiste je
pense que c'est c'est satisfaisant après
l'ordre juridique européen bon j'ai
donné quelques éléments de réponse dans
ce que j'ai dit à l'intention du
président en bas et et de vous-même
euh monsieur Vassel pose la question
j'ai du mal à me relire tellement j'ai
écré des pattes de bouche est-ce que le
Conseil constitutionnel ne se prononce
pas en opportunité parfois plutôt grande
question grande question grande question
euh et puis on pourrait dans le même
veine dire mais est-ce que c'est une
institution politique bon hein c'eston
je dirais que les décisions du conseil
sont ou doivent être non pas politiques
mais elles ont une portée politique
souvent bon il a une distinction entre
les deux
euh il faut se prononcer en droit mais
euh faut éviter que le droit soit
inopportun bon
euh dans les qualités la liste des
qualités comme ça qu'il faut cocher j'ai
dit bon l'indépendance c'est important
l'expérience la compétence et le bon
sens alors est-ce que le bon sens veut
dire l'opportunité j'en sais rien si euh
mais le droit et le droit en même temps
et pas tordre le droit et le tel que
étit fabriqué le Conseil constitutionnel
son travail d'abord c'est de vérifier la
conformité à la Constitution alors il a
étendu la Constitution c'est pas
simplement les articles de la
Constitution c'est aussi préambule et
cetera
voilà je je ne croyez pas que je m'en
sorte par une pirouette mais je vais
citer jores et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que le le président
Debray dans son dernier discours faisait
référence à je reste donc je peux
mutoriser la même liberté euh dans le
discours fameux vous savez qu'il fait à
la jeunesse en 1903 alors il décrit le
courage bon et il y a toute une série
une espèce de d'énumération qu'est-ce
que c'est que le courage et
euh à un moment il utilise cette formule
devenue célèbre le courage c'est d'aller
à l'idéal et de comprendre le réel au
fond c'est un peu la même chose bon il
faut euh absolument respecter le droit
et comprendre le réel bon sinon bon mais
le droit c'est le droit voilà le droit
c'est le droit et ce n'est pas à vous
qui faites le droit c'est pas vous qu'
faut convaincre mais parfois dans
l'opinion public c'est évidemment plus
compliqué euh
Sénat première lecture non oui
collectivité locale je vois le le le
sujet alors
euh et c'est un sujet qui n'est pas
abstrait puisque notamment je crois
avoir compris qu'il y a eu une certaine
polémique dans différentes occasions et
notamment
sur À propos des cumuls bon qui devait
avoir le dernier mot et cetera et cetera
bon pas facile euh et je ne vais pas
dire ni la position que je prendrai au
casù ni revenir à une façon critique sur
la jur prudence ce serait complètement
déplacé de ma part mais je vois bien
quels sont les deux éléments qui peuvent
venir
euh dans la contradiction et je pense
notamment à la décision sur sur les
cumul et la question de savoir si oui ou
non c'était un texte relatif au Sénat et
bon d'un
côté certain nombre de personnes euh
peuvent dire bah écoutez c'est un texte
qui touche le Sénat
donc il est relatif au Sénat
et les textes sont
clairs lorsque un texte est relatif au
Sénat ça un certain nombre de conclusion
de conséquences sur la loi organique et
il faut que ce soit voté conforme et
cetera ça c'est une approche de l'autre
et j'ai comprendre que c'est celle qui a
prévalu dans la décision dont il s'agit
dit oui mais ça ne concerne le Sénat
que si ça concerne l'équilibre des
pouvoirs entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
donc comme les dispositions sont les
mêmes que ce soit les sénateurs ou les
députés on peut pas dire que ça concerne
ça je vais pas trancher mais j'ai bien
compris que c'était ça les deux
postulations bon pour le reste
moi je crois que le rôle du Conseil
c'est je viens de le dire d'appliquer
les
textes et de faire en sorte en tout cas
que le Sénat
soit entendu bon et respecté euh pas
seulement parce que je vous ai dit ma
conviction sur le bicamérisme mais parce
que voilà c'est ce sont nos
institutions le Sénat doit être entendu
et d'autant plus entendu que sur un
certain nombre de sujets il apporte me
semble-t-il
une philosophie une approche euh qui est
singulière mais qui concourt à l'intérêt
général d'une façon
éminente merci Monsieur Premier ministre
ses réponses
très
approfondies nous avons maintenant le
président
mard alors on fait comme comme vous le
souhaitez trois collègues vont vous
poser leurs question et puis nous ferons
une
ultime un ultime échange volontier
président alors président dans mesarts
Monsieur le Premier Ministre je ne vous
reposerai pas la question sur le
bicamérisme vous l' poser il y a peu et
vous venez de nous répondre à nouveau je
ne vous poserai pas la question sur les
autorités administratives indépendantes
vous avez fait la réponse et je j' suis
heureux de cette réponse et en ce qui
concerne la 3ème question sur ce qui
s'est passé pour le
cumul votre
réponse nous laisse ni dans l'espoir ni
dans le
désespoir c'est
exact euh j'aurais deux questions une
sur euh la sisine du Conseil
constitutionnel parce que il est
aujourd'hui plus facile euh de saisir le
Conseil constitutionnel certes après un
filtre dans le domaine des questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalité que
de trouver 60 parlementaires pour faire
un
recours ne pensez-vous pas qu'il
faudrait une évolution à ce niveau-là et
par exemple c'est un exemple mais ça
pourrait être autrement de considérer
que un groupe parlementaire peut saisir
le Conseil constitutionnel mais c'est
une idée comme une
autre
deuxè parce que c'est difficile quand on
n'est pas dans un des deux grand groupe
de trouver 60 signatures j'en sais
quelque chose je l'ai
fait je je voisà je voisà votre
formation conseil d'État mon cher
collègue la deuxème question c'est sur
l'évolution du Conseil constitutionnel
lui-même d'ailleurs vous y avez déjà
fait
allusion la question qui se pose est de
savoir si l'on va vers une sorte de cour
suprême et et et et est-ce que c'est
quel est votre votre avis là-dessus et
et vous avez dit d'ailleurs ça me per
permet de de relier les les deux axes de
cette question vous avez dit ce qui est
important et je le crois aussi c'est
l'image du droit français et dans le
monde nous avons une tradition et cette
tradition
elle repose beaucoup sur les droits de
l'homme et il y a quand même un débat
aujourd'hui sur la question des libertés
individuelles la loi constitutionnelle
du 3 juin
1958 parle des libertés individuelles
et au fil des ans on a eu une évolution
autour de l'article 66 de la
Constitution vers la notion de la
liberté individuelle et vous savez où je
veux en venir par rapport d'ailleurs à à
des expressions
récentes de la Cour de cassation c'est
qui est le primat de nos grandes
institutions sur la question des
libertés individuelles et je je crois
que par rapport à la question de
l'évolution vers ou non un système de
Cour suprême je crois qu'on est au cœur
du
débat merci chers collègue monsieur
Portelli merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre je voulais
vous poser deux questions une de fond et
une autre de
déontologie le il a été remarqué à
plusieurs re reprise dans le débat que
le l'évolution de ces derniers temps
liée d'une part au développement du
contrôle de alé d'autre part
l'introduction des questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalitée la
place du Conseil constitutionnel alors
il faut se situ aussi du point de vue de
ceux qui saisissent le conseil qu'il
soit parlementaire ou praticien du droit
ils ont noté que la Cour de cassation
met la priorité la primoté sur le
contrôle de conventionnalité par rapport
au contrôle de constitutionnalité et
puis note aussi que pour eu le contrôle
de constitutionnalité c'est une
opportunité de procédure entre lesquels
ils arbitrent tantôt ils préféreront
aller à la conventionnalité tantôt à la
constitutionnalité et ils ne se
tourneront vers le Conseil
constitutionnel qu'ussi longtemps que le
Conseil fera preuve de la célérité qu'il
qu'il a aujourd'hui en matière de
jugement des affaires qui lui sont
soumises or nous avons noté ces derniers
temps certains signes inquiétants euh le
Conseil a certes des questions de
prioritairees de constitutionnalité à
examiné mais il a aussi les saisignes du
Parlement et ces ces saisignes se sont
diversifié nous nous avons par exemple
aujourd'hui aussi l'évaluation des des
études d'impact or nous avons remarqué
ces derniers temps à plusieurs reprises
que le Conseil n'avait pas eu
matériellement le temps de faire
sérieusement son travail sur
l'évaluation des études d'impact et pour
nous c'est un vrai problème d'ù la
question que je vous pose Monsieur le
Premier Ministre est-ce que vous pensez
en tant que futur Président si vous êtes
élu est-ce que vous pensez que le
Conseil aujourd'hui a les moyens
matériel et humain d'exercer toutes ces
fonctions et j'en arrive à ma question
desontologie que je pose au au futur
président du Conseil
constitutionnel monsieur le Président
est-ce que vous vous engagez à faire en
sorte que le président du Conseil
constitutionnel soit le président nommé
par le Président de la République et non
pas le secrétaire général du Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce que vous vous
engagez en tant que président du Conseil
constitutionnel si vous être nommé à ne
pas saisir les groupes parlementaires
pour leur demander de ne pas déposer de
cisine
à ne pas déjeuner avec des
parlementaires pour leur demander de
déposer ou de ne pas déposer des
amendements à des lois en cours de
discussion au Parlement et que
ferez-vous lorsque des lois qui sont
examinées par le
Conseil ont été traité par vous à un
titre ou un autre en tant que Premier
ministre ou en tant que ministre de la
République
merci merci chers collègues enfin
Monsieur le compte puis monsieur Fabius
répondra aux trois intervenants qui
viennent de s'exprimer qui viendront de
s'exprimer quand vous l'aurez fait chers
collègues merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre l'évolution
du du du Conseil été
souvent évoqué lors de cette audition
puisque'au début elle était il était
considéré comme un simple régulateur de
l'activité des pouvoirs publics
euh est-ce que les évolutions depuis
1962 pourrai conduire aujourd'hui le
Conseil constitutionnel face à une
saisine comme celle
du président du Sénat en 1962 sur un
usage de l'article 11 pour modifier la
Constitution a évolué par rapport à aux
décisions de 1962 cont tenu de
l'évolution du rôle du Conseil
constitutionnel qui alors que la saisine
portait sur l'usage de l'article
pour faire passer une loi qui avait
finalement vocation à changer la
Constitution
sans passer par l'article 89 qui est
chargé de de de cela est-ce que vous
considérez que les évolutions du
Conseil ferait évoluer euh la la
décision une décision aujourd'hui du
conseil sur ce sujet la deuxième est un
peu en opposition ou dans le même esprit
que celle de H Portelli
euh l'article 89 précise que on ne peut
pas changer la constitution lorsqu'il
est porté atteintte à l'intégrité du
territoire on comprend bien pourquoi et
la question que je je souhaiterais vous
poser sur ce sujet c'est contenu de des
arguments de menace qui sont utilisés
aujourd'hui euh sur pour justifier la
réforme constitutionnelle en cours
est-ce que vous considérez qu'il y a une
contradiction
entre cette partie de l'article 89 de
notre Constitution et l'engagement d'une
une réforme constitutionnelle dans le
contexte de guerre que le gouvernement
rappelle souvent je
vous monsur sur le premier point je je
est-ce que vous pouvez répéter parce que
j'ai pas très bien compris la première
de vos observations question la première
question oui oui la première question
c'est c'est c'est de de de savoir si
contenu de l'évolution du rôle du
Conseil constitutionnel depuis
1962 vous considérez que la réponse que
le Conseil constitutionnel a fait à
l'époque
euh au à la au président du Sénat qui
euh
euh en fait souhaitait l'avis du conseil
sur l'usage par le Président de la
République de l'article 11 de la
Constitution pour modifier pour par une
loi soumise à référendum modifier la
Constitution sans passer par l'article
89 est-ce que vous considérez que les
évolutions et les et et et les décisions
du Conseil et je pense en particulier à
celles qui ont eu lieu au moment du
référendum de 2005 font qu'aujourd'hui
la le conseil aurait une attitude
différente que de considérer que
finalement le peuple est
souverain tel qu'il peut être
constituant à lui tout seul en dépit de
tout ce qu'il y a dans la Constitution
merci excusez-moi j'avis j'avais pas
saisi maintenant je je comprends alors
euh je vais
prendre voilà d'abord merci le président
mzard
euh
donc c'est concentrer sur deux
questions la sisine et puis l'évolution
du Conseil constionnelle Cour suprême et
sur la question de la
sisine vous dites désormais il est plus
facile
de saisir par une QPC que de réunir les
voies
nécessaires 60 pour avoir la saisine
il y a quand même des
conditions précises pour que la QPC
prospère ces conditions vous les
connaissez et elles font
que jusqu'à présent on s'est stabilisé
je crois autour de 70 bon il faut que le
motif soit sérieux il faut que ce soit
applicable enfin vous connaissez
ça il faut éviter évidemment que euh la
QPC soit un moyen dilatoire et de ce que
j'ai vu euh j'ai l'impression que euh il
y a un équilibre qui a été trouvé au
départ de ce que j'ai cru comprendre la
Cour de cassation était un petit peu
rétissante bon et puis maintenant les
choses se sont stabilisées et le
filtrage par la Cour de cassation d'un
côté par le Conseil d'État apparaît
satisfaisant les délais sont respectés
les 3 mois je crois qu'il est arrivé
deux ou trois fois simplement que les
délais ne soient pas respectés qu cas
automatiquement le Conseil a été saisi
euh et il s'agit bien évidemment
d'ouvrir ce droit nouveau aux citoyens
mais c'est le sens de ce que je disais
par rapport aux autorités
administratives il s'agit non plus de
faire en sorte que tout
ça soit tellement largement ouvert que
ça devienne impossible à traiter alors
l'autre volet c'est les 60 bon
euh j'hésiterais
à faire dépendre cela de la notion de
groupe parlementaire parce que de mes
souvenirs de président de l'Assemblée
nationale je crois que la notion de
groupe parlementaire est assez évolutive
et d'ailleurs c'est probablement
vous-même qui
devez déci et pour des raisons
que seul la voûte céleste permet de
comprendre sat tend comme me le
soufflait le président B juste raison
plutôt vers la diminution que vers
l'extension
bon et puis je crois que sans que ces
règles soient coulé dans le bronze il
faut tout de même qu'il y ait un chiffre
qui soit défini qui ne dépende pas de
situation potique qui elle-même peut
peut changer euh donc moi je je si vous
voulez je crois que la question du
nombre des parlementaires nécessaires
pour euh opérer la Chine est une
question en soi il ne faut pas faire
dépendre de la procédure cUPC ce sont
deux procédures différentes mais mais
voilà euh donc en tout état de cause
c'est au constituant à à le décider
euh et donc je reprends tout à fait
la formule que vous avez très gentiment
prononcé pour une autre de mes réponses
il n'y a ni espoir ni désespoir euh en
ce qui concerne l'évolution du Conseil
constitutionnel
euh Cour
suprême bon la Cour suprême des
États-Unis est une grande institution
mais c'est une tradition tout à fait
différente et je ne vois pas honnêtement
que nous lancions dans un bouleversement
de l'organisation institutionnelle
française où on fusionnerait la Cour de
cassation le Conseil d'État on mettrait
tout ça sous la dépendance du cons
euh donc moi je pense que euh il faut là
aussi que il y ait un dialogue des juges
mais je pense finalement que que
l'équilibre français euh est assez euh
satisfaisant alors pour ce qui concerne
euh qui a la primauté sur la liberté
individuelle grande question j'ai cru
comprendre que il y a eu des
déclarations récemment de telle ou telle
autorité de la Cour de
cassation se prononçant ledessus euh bon
pour des raisons que vous comprendrez
très bien président mard je ne veux pas
à ce stade trancher là-dessus simplement
je voudrais dire de la façon la plus
nette que euh j'ai tout à fait
conscience
euh de l'attachement du Sénat et en
particulier de cette commission à la
protection des libertés publique et
j'observe c'est
incontestable que dans le travail
parlementaire la contribution de votre
commission du Sénat en général est tout
à fait éminente et je voudrais citer
deux exemples récents qui sont
incontestables concernant la loi
relative au renseignement donc ça ça
date de l'été
2015 il fallait renforcer les capacités
d'action des services et en même temps
garantir que on ne porte pastinte
excessive au droits fondamentaux de nos
concitoyens
et j'ai de mes collaborateurs m'a montré
une petite étude sur ce qu'avait fait le
Sénat
pour inscrire les activités de
renseignement au cœur des principes
juridiques fondateurs et je pense que
vous avez fait un travail de ce point de
vue là que je considère comme exemplaire
donc ça on est dans le le concret et de
même en ce qui concerne l'état d'urgence
je veux pas me prononcer là-dessus parce
qu' on va avoir des éléments
d'application mais disons pour le passé
euh les travaux du Sénat sur les deux
lois de prorogation de l'état d'urgence
ont montré votre souci constant des
liberté publique de nos concitoyens et
évidemment cette préoccupation du Sénat
ça se rattache direct directement au
cœur de l'activité du Conseil
constitutionnel
euh donc tout ce qui ira dans ce sens-là
je pense que ce sera excellent
euh je ne veux pas être plus précis
président et vous le comprendrai
aisément en ce qui concerne monsieur
Portelli euh contrôle constitutionnalité
contrôle conventionnalité et votre
approche est j'espère que vous ne serez
pas uré par très intéressante parce
qu'elle est pratique vous dit bon c'est
très bien mais est-ce qu'on a les moyens
pratiques et cetera bon et en
particulier la question de la célérité
du jugement euh pour le moment euh des
chiffres que j'ai qui sont certainement
exact
euh les choses sont
euh satisfaisantes me semble-t-il euh à
la fois parce que la Cour de cassation
et le conseil d'État ont respecté les
délais et parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel a respecté les délis
donc on peut pas dire que le fait qu'il
a un contrôle de constitutionnalité et
pas de contrôle de conventionnalité est
été mise en défaut parce que les délais
n'étaient pas
respectés mais il faudra être très
vigilant et je pense pas que cela puisse
jouer pour la juridiction administrative
parce que les choses sont ainsi faites
que une affaire ne va pas être instruite
tant que la question du contrôle ne sera
pas
résolue je lisais dansun journal de de
ce matin
que en ce qui concerne l'ordre
judiciaire ça pouvait poser des
problèmes parce qu'il y avait des
audiencements qui étaient prévus qui
tout d'un coup étaient impossible
parce que des juges avaient prévu un
certain calendrier que tout d'un coup
était bouleversé donc peut-être là il y
aura-t-il quelque chose à faire mais en
tout cas pour le
moment ayant consulté pas mal de de
personnes avant cette
audition on m'a pas souligné une
difficulté particulière s'il avait une
il faudra bien sûr y
répondre je suis plus préoccupé donc ça
si M donné de le voir je le verrai par
ce que vous me dites sur les études
d'impact parce que bon c'est pas très
facile bien sûr à opérer mais là aussi
il faut respecter la loi euh les moyens
euh nous sommes tous économes des deners
publics mais enfin il faut aussi que les
institution de la République puisse
fonctionner correctement je sais qu'il y
a beaucoup de travail au Conseil
constitutionnel ça tout le monde me le
dit et que par rapport à une époque
antérieure les choses sont probablement
différentes mais
euh aucun de ceux qui sont pressentis
va-t-il sembler pour y siéger ou de ceux
qui actuellement y siègent ne Rechin à
travailler bon euh en même temps il faut
disposer des moyens nécessaires je vous
ferai une réponse très concrète de la
part de quelqu'un qui a dirigé bien sûr
de grandes administrations
euh le Président si j'ai compris il faut
que ce soit le président et non pas
quelqu'un d'autre hein c'est c'était ça
en gros écoutez
euh que puis-je vous répondre d'une part
que la réputation des personnes qui
travaillent au conseilal est excellente
et que s'agissant de la mienne je n'ai
pas la réputation de ne pas exercer les
fonctions qu'on me confie bon ça il pas
difficulté à se mettre d'accord
là-dessus bon parfois on me reproche
d'exercer des fonctions qu'on ne m'a pas
confié ça non non ça non ça dieu m'en
garde et la Constitution mais celle
qu'on confie j'essaierai j'essaierai bon
et puis alors et nous avions un apporté
avec le président bas euh je ne vois pas
du tout à quelle pratique vous faites
allusion ilut il faut pas déjeuner et
cetera bon euh là aussi bon il faut être
très attentif
euh d'un côté bon l'indépendance c'est
l'indépendance de l'autre bon nous
sommes dans une société ouverte bon et
je voudrais pas lorsque je saluerai AES
dans le futur tel ou tel d'entre vous
que ce soit perçu par vous comme une
atteinte à votre indépendance ou à la
mienne bon bon mais je pense qu'on porte
ça en soi et puis au Conseil consel il y
a quand même une une une précaution je
ne sais pas qui disait c'est que quand
eu des conditions d'âge et d'autres dans
lesquelles on est élu on a rien à
atteindre et rien rien à attendre et
rien à redouter bon c'est assez juste
donc c'est c'est un un bon adjuvant pour
l'indépendance supposez même qu'on n pas
une disposition spontanée pour pour
cette indépendant et on peut pas être
renouvelé donc voilà euh alors se
déporter oui bien sûr euh lorsqu'il y
aura euh
une une question qui viendra et euh par
exemple une loi que j'aurais porté bon
je pourrais pas siéger en même temps
faisons attention à la jurisprudence
j'ai regardé ça qui
euh a dit que euh le fait qu'on est été
pourrais pas répéter par cœur mais enfin
le fait qu'on est été associé à tel ou
tel élément d'une délibération ne
signifie pas automatiquement qu'on
doivent se déporter hein et on le
comprend parce que sinon cont tenu de la
composition du conseil euh on a du mal à
trouver bon donc c'est une c'est une
discipline que que que on doit
s'appliquer en ce qui concerne les QPC
c'est pas seulement une discipline il y
a une règle de droit si une révocation
est demandée par une des partis euh ou
bien vous l'acceptez de vous-même ou
bien si vous ne l'acceptez pas les
autres membres du collège délibère pour
savoir si vous pouvez participer ou non
voilà mais il faut être très très
attentif à tout cela parce que ça c'est
un principe qui vaut pour la justice en
général et pour le conseil constionnel
en particulier il faut pas que la
décision soit seulement juste il faut
qu'elle soit perçue comme juste hein
hein et donc il faut être très attentif
euh et je dirais très prudent sur ces
matières de de
déontologie Monsieur le Comte ah oui
excusez-moi monsieur le comte euh qui a
posé la question 62 article 89 et cetera
alors
euh on va pas refaire l'histoire et euh
soyons attentifs au fait là aussi que je
ne vais pas prendre de position sur des
sujets sur lesquels je pourrais àis
avoir à me prononcer euh si je rejoins
le conseil
mais je crois que il a été euh
reconnu que
euh la loi
euh qui est votée directement par le
peuple français référendom
et d'une portée peut-être différente
dans le ô qu'elle permet que la loi si
je puis dire
ordinaire
et je pense que il serait difficile de
revenir sur cette approche parce que le
peuple est le peuple vous êtes les
représentants du peuple mais quand il y
a une expression directe évidemment ça
une force particulière en ce qui
concerne les questions de l'article 89
et etetera et cetera euh là j'espère que
vous m'tiendrez pasgur monsieur le conte
mais le Conseil non seulement risque
mais va sûrement être saisi des textes
d'application de tout cela donc je ne
voudrais pas me trouver dans une
position en porte à FAO cont tenu même
de ce que je viens de répondre à
Monsieur Portelli
euh voilà mais soyez sûr en tout cas que
ces questions si elles doivent être
examinées sera examiné avec à l'esprit à
la fois la défense des libertés
publiques manière extrêmement étroite et
le Sénat évidemment un rôle éminent à
jouer en ce sens et en même temps le
fait que vous êtes bien conscient chacun
est bien conscient du fait que l'État
doit fonctionner et continuer à
fonctionner y compris dans les périodes
aussi difficiles que
maintenant monsieur le Président
euh on prend une
autre oui alors monsieur vous avez la
possibilité et nos collègues à venir
vont faire un effort de concision dans
la formulation de leurs questions que
nous n'avons pas imposé à leur
prédécesseurs le président chur Monsieur
Alain Richard et Monsieur van DIREN donc
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier ministre vous avez déjà
répondu à toutes les questions
auxquelles j'avais j'avais pensé je
profiterai donc du fait que j'ai la
parole pour dire que par rapport à la
question question de l'étude d'impact
j'ai pour ma part une grande prudence
parce que j'imagine le cas où le conseil
se mettrait examiner toutes les lignes
et les paragraphes de l'étude d'impact
quand il y a pas d'étude d'impact il y
en a pas là on peut considérer que mais
j'ai toujours pensé pour ma part que
l'impact d'un projet de loi faisait
partie du débat politique et voilà mais
je dis ça parce que j'ai la parole mais
j'avais une j'avais une autre
question j'ai été je suis rapporteur
pour avis pour notre commission des
crédits du Conseil
constitutionnel comme ça j'aurai
peut-être l'occasion de venir vous voir
si vous
êtes désigné et et j'ai remarqué que les
crédits si cette démarche est jugée
déontologique ah oui elle est très
déontologi sû qu'on déjeune pas ensemble
non non mais on ne déjeunera pas
peut-être aurais-je droit un verre d'eau
monsieur Jean-Louis Debray m'a offert un
café et je je l'avoue devant les membres
de la commission et euh donc j'ai pu
observer qu'au cours des six dernières
années les crédits de fonctionnement le
le coût de fonctionnement du Conseil
avait diminué chaque année et euh donc
il y a eu une certaine rigueur que je
tiens à noter dans l'organisation du
conseil pourevenir sur ce qu'a dit tout
à l'heure madame
taska il y a eu un redéploiement des
personnels en terme de de de de compéten
pour faire face justement au QPC alors
je je ne vous demanderai pas si vous
continuez si vous entendez continuer
dans le dans le même sens je sais que
vous êtes attaché à la rigueur du
fonctionnement tout simplement parce que
dans notre dernier rapport j'ai écrit et
la commission n'y a pas vu de
difficultés que eu égard aux efforts qui
avaient été fait il paraissait difficile
d'aller au-delà donc je me permets de
vous le dire mais ça ne veut pas
forcément dire qu'il est
indispensable d'aller en de ça voyez ce
que je veux
dire merci chers collègues monsieur Alan
richichard
oui moi jeis faire simplement deux
observations que que le le Premier
ministre fabus comprendra et peut-être
consentira-t-il un commentaire mais la
première c'est que nous sommes forcément
tentés quand on s'adresse un
représentant ou un futur représentant du
Conseil constitutionnel de parler de la
Constitution mais j'ai fait observer que
le Conseil constitutionnel n'est en rien
inconstituant c'est-à-dire que quand on
fait l'énonciation complète de ces
attributions aucune ne concerne la
démarche de réforme de la Constitution
et puis sur le point de la QPC de son
évolution quand on regarde et je je fais
partie d'une famille politique qui
réclamait de longuees dates c'est accès
de des citoyens
euh au juges constitutionnels pour faire
apprécier si euh les les grands
principes euh représentant le bloc de
constitutionnalité étaé
respecté mais quand on dit les citoyens
ça ne peut pas être tout un chacun c'est
dire que aucun des pays qui pratiquent
ce contrôle de constitutionnalité ouvert
ne le fait sans filtrage et l'exemple
extrême c'est précisément la cour la
Cour suprême américaine qui doit juger
alors qu'elle représente l'équivalent de
la cour de Cass du Conseil d'État et du
Conseil constitutionnel 300 ou 500
affaires par an c'està dire à peu près
le diè peut-être même pas de ce que font
nos juridictions suprêmes et donc avant
qu'on évolue sur ce sujet-là moi je fais
observer que le système qui a été adopté
en 2008 et dans la loi organique c'est
un système qui ne passe que par des
juges c'estd que pour qu'une question
arrive devant le conseil il faut que au
moins deux examens collégiaux par des
juges qualifié aboutissent à dire c'est
une vraie question qui n'a pas encore
été
tranchée
ça c'est une vraie garantie bien entendu
ça signifie qu'on élimine des tas de
question mais ça veut dire que celle qui
passe sont vraiment pertinentes et vont
faire
évoluerapéciation du droit
constitutionnel si on sort de
ça sachant en plus que il y a un très
fort appétit au
barreau c'est devenu un signe extérieur
de prestige dans cette honorable et très
nombreuse
profession d'avoir fait une QPC alors à
forceuie de l'avoir gagné c'est vrai
c'est un sujet de
compétition
professionnel dans le barreau dont on a
probablement pas encore vu tous les
effets donc il me semble que c'est une
réforme importante on a été nombreux à
la saluer pour certains on l'expérit
depuis longtemps moi je salue la la
démarche du Premier ministre faus de
dire bon on va déjà faire un bilan et on
va apprécier parce que il faut que ça
Arve tout ça s contrôle moi ma question
elle est au fond ça s'appelle toujours
conseil pas bien que tout le monde a
conclu ce qui le bon sens que c'est une
juridiction et donc il y a quand même
quelque chose qui est un peu dérangeant
quand on est Conseil d'État on comprend
bien cette question là c'est au fond
nous ne pouvons jamais demander conseil
au
Conseil
rien dans la Constitution noffre de
prise
à une approche de recommandation ou
d'avertissement émanant du conseil et
honnêtement je vois pas comment on
pourrait biaiser par rapport à
ça
donc moi je constate qu'il a un outil a
de outil c'est la rédaction même des
décisions peutêre plus ou moins
explicite et plus ou moins pédagogique
je crois que le Conseil songe à ça et
puis y a ce qu'on appelle la nouvelle
formule des cahers c'està-dire d'un
commentaire al lui qui a vraiment
vocation à être je
dirais se mettre à la place des usagers
du droit constitutionnel et nous en
sommes
pour rendre familier au raisonnement qui
a conduit le Conseil constitutionnel à
adopter t disposition et notamment quand
sagit de censurer une loi de manière que
nous soyons capablebl d'anticiper parce
que ça ça devient un débat maintenant
assez présent dans nos débats
législatifs de dire est-ce que nous
avons un risque avec le
conseil donc moi je vis en tout cas
rendre le le future j'espère président
du Conseil constitutionnel sensible à
cette question sur laquelle faut pas
qu'on improvise il faut pas qu'on qu'on
fasse de d'innovation imprudente mais
qui suppose forcément que nous ayons un
outil de dialogue au moins à postériori
en disant voilà ce que nous avons jugé
et ce que ça peut signifier pour les
prochains débats que vous aurez ultime
question de Monsieur René vandiren donc
ça sera très court tout d'abord Monsieur
le Premier
Ministre un petit souvenir j'étais
directeur de cabinet du merire de roubet
quand jeune premier ministre déjà jeune
premier ministre vous êtes venu et la
période vousoulais cela vous aviez mis
en
exerg le
caractère
novateur des de la loi des grandes lois
sur la
décentralisation et vous aviez parce que
ça m'est resté dans la tête vous aviez
utilisé une image qui était de
dire l'accentuation du pouvoir des
préfets et leur pouvoir d'adaptation
c'est-à-dire la
déconcentration
et le transfert des compétences au
collectivité territorial
élu si vous voulez parce que vous avez
déjà une puissance métaphorique énorme
euh ça ressemble à un couple en
mécanique alors au titre de l'ultime
dialogue entre élus territoriaux et
avant que vous prononciez vos vœux pour
entrer dans cette noble institution il y
a en France un gros problème de ce
pouvoir des préfets et des adaptations
des normes voilà bien monsieur le
Premier ministre vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup de de de du contenu de
vos questions et
et je dirais de de leur tonalité par
rapport euh à Jean-Pierre Sueur
euh si j'ai bien compris il nous
conseille sur les études d'impact tout
de même d'une certaine prudence
euh et sur les crédits de fonctionnement
il note que
euh le conseil sous la présidence jeanlb
a été économe et sans nous conseiller
d'aller dans le sens inverse
euh il dit bon il faut tout de même que
il y ait les moyens nécessaires pour
fonctionner donc tout ça me paraî
empreint d'une grande sagesse euh Alain
Richard pose des questions de fond
compliqué euh sur la
QPC
c'est vrai que c'est un
succès mais il faut pas non plus que le
succès soit
tellement large que il devienne nous en
parlions à voix basse avec mon voisin
une espèce de d'effet de mode et puis
que avec de bonnes intentions on
aboutisse à un résultat différents de
celui qu'on espérait il y a des
conditions vous l'avez souligné monsieur
Richard euh conditions juridiques bon il
faut que la disposition soit applicable
au litige ou à la procédure constittu le
fondement des poursuites il faut que la
disposition n'ait pas déjà été déclarée
conforme à la Constitution dans les
motif et le dispositif de décision du
Conseil sauf changement des
circonstances et il faut que la question
ne soit pas dépourvue de caractère
sérieux pour que on évite ce qui est
fantaisiste ou euh dilatoire et conseil
la Cour de cassation doivent y veiller
euh on me dit que après des débuts qui
peut-être ont était un peu incertain
maintenant ces critères sont désormais
correctement appréciés par tout le monde
euh et il faut quand même être très
attentif d'où cette idée du bilan là
j'ai des chiffres que vous devez avoir
aussi le Conseil d'État et la Cour de
cassation ont eu
depuis le 1er mars 2010 qui était le le
début de la mise en application a traité
2600 dossier de QPC
2600 ils en ont transmis 538 au Conseil
c'est-à-dire environ 20
%. et dans seulement 3
cas la QPC a fait l'objet d'un examen
par le Conseil à défaut d'avoir été
examiné dans le délai des 3 mois pour
par le Conseil d'État ou la cour de
casasse
euh il faudra être très attentif
euh c'est un droit nouveau maintenant
euh l'excès tue euh cette possibilité
donc faisons un bilan et nous verrons si
les choses sont pratiquées correctement
ou bien s'il y a une espèce de
détournement bon moi je ne suis pas en
capacité aujourd'hui de le dire les
chiffres qu'on m'a cité les commentaires
qui m'ont a été fait euh me laisse
penser que
euh les choses sont maîtrisées mais
enfin il faudra être attentif alors
Monsieur Richard soulève une autre
question
euh il dit mais le Conseil est-ce que ça
correspond vraiment au au titre de
l'activité qui est pratiquée et au-delà
de cette question de vocabulaire euh
comment fait-on pour euh prévoir la
jurisprudence saisir et cetera alors une
idée a été
euh développée euh par certains sur
laquelle
euh le Conseil pourrait être saisi euh
par davantage d'autorités je laisse de
côté les autorités administratives mais
euh on
pourrait avant telle ou telle décision
et avant même de prendre une loi
euh saisir le Conseil euh il y a une
procédure vous le savez au Conseil
d'État mais ça on le
comprend bon le Conseil d'État est saisi
par exemple des décrets et puis ensuite
il peut être saisi au contentieux
euh mais là l'organisation pratique le
permet puisque le Conseil d'État il y a
certains beaucoup plus de membres que au
Conseil constitutionnel et donc euh on
peut administrer les choses de telle
manière que ce son pas les mêmes qui
donnent leur opinion au moment de la
saisine préalable ou les mêmes qui
jugent au contentieux évidment au
Conseil constitutionnel ça poserait un
problème énorme puisque nous sommes neuf
plus en l'occurrence de membres de
droit on voit pas comment on pourrait
faire deux formations mais mais et c'est
peut-être une remarque de fond que je me
permets outre la question pratique je ne
sais pas comment on pourrait la régler
il y a quand même une autre question qui
est évidemment il faut que on connaisse
la jurisprudence mais admettons que vous
puissiez saisir le Conseil avant et puis
ensuite après mais quelle liberté il
vous reste quelle marge vous
avez et c'est là où le fait d'avoir été
40 ans parlementair joue
euh on m'a l'autre jour posé la question
à l'Assemblée nationale c'était la
dernière réponse que j'ai apporté et
elle valait pour l'assemblée comme pour
le Sénat j'ai dit c'est quand même ici
le Parlement qui est le cœur de la
démocratie c'est comme ça ça veut pas
dire que tout soit parfait bon si et le
conseil il a un rôle spécifique à jouer
mais ce n'est pas le
Parlement si vous vous en sert en amont
en AM mal au milieu et cetera qu'est-ce
qui bon c'est quand même une question
dans l'équilibre des pouvoirs qui est
très importante indépendant du fait
qu'il y a des dispositions pratiques
qu'on ne pourrait pas prendre comp tenu
de notre nombre simplement là où
Monsieur Richard a raison il faut malgré
on dit en latin impératoria brvitas il
faut que les jugements enfin en tout cas
c'est notre tradition soit soit bien
libelllé et court concis mais en même
temps il faut qu'il soit compr ible
d'ailleurs l'accessibilité
l'intelligibilité c'est maintenant
devenu un élément important je crois que
c'est une bonne chose donc il faut il y
a des commentaires qui doivent être fait
qui doivent être autorisés mais
spontanément je je ne serais pas
favorable à ce qu'il y ait des saisines
en amont parce que sinon à ce moment-là
vous êtes
paralysé après par rapport à ce que dit
Monsieur van donc oui je n'avais pas le
le le souvenir
j'avais le souvenir d'avoir été mais
j'avais pas le souvenir des déclarations
que j'avais fait certainement immortelle
sur la décentralisation mais sur le
fond je crois ne pas avoir changé d'avis
avec les années sur ce point moi je suis
un partisan de la décentralisation mais
l'état ça
existe ça doit exister donc si la
décentralisation est poussée l'État doit
être fort fort ça veut pas dire présent
partout parce que sinon bon alors la
République cesse d'être une et
indivisible ça devient une série de
territoires et cetera et ça c'est pas la
conception de la
Constitution donc pas la conception que
nous avons les uns les autres euh
monsieur le Président mesdame messieurs
je comprends que c'est la fin de cette
audition donc je vous remercie c'est
aussi probablement la fin de mon
expression publique sur beaucoup de
sujets
et donc je veux vous remercier puis vous
dire que j'ai toujours
été heureux au Sénat à
cause de l'atmosphère qui règne la
politique c'est pas la guerre civile et
on peut dire des choses forte tout en
étant courtois et en étant favorable au
dialogue et c'est ce que j'ai toujours
vécu au Sénat merci beaucoup monsieur le
Premier ministre nous avons prolongé
cette C audition avec le sentiment que
c'était la dernière que nous pourrions
avoir pour profiter de vos analyses et
donc nous sommes heureux de toutes les
réponses que vous avez pu nous apporter
mes chers collègues nous allons nous
rendre sans tarder pour pouvoir voter à
12h30 car l'Assemblée nationale attend
le dépouillement de la commission des
lois vous savez que nous additionnons
les voix des députés des sénateur et les
nominations sont possibles si il il n y
a pas plus de
35è des membres des deux commissions des
lois des deux assemblées qui s'opposent
à ces nominations monsieur le Premier
ministre je vous remercie merci à vous
voilà pour cette matinée du Sénat
consacré aux auditions de deux candidats
au Conseil constitutionnel notamment
Laurent fabus l'ancien ministre des
Affaires étrangères vous pouvez toujours
voir et revoir toutes les auditions sur
notre site sur publsenat.fr prochain
rendez-vous de l'actualité parlementaire
cet après-midi avec Sénat 360 à 15h
présenté par Jérôme Rabier très bonne
journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires